so if you have any type of mucus okay
there's a really simple and expensive
solution whether it's pneumonia
bronchitis sinus congestion COPD asthma
or even if you have a tonsillitis or
sore throat you can apply this and it's
basically using salt there's been a long
history that goes way back to the 1700s
or even a lot earlier of using certain
types of salt therapy especially for
your immune system doctors back then
were recommending going to the Sea right
breathing in that Sea Air other people
recommended sea bathing and even they've
noticed people working in the salt mines
rarely got sick you know when everyone
else is getting sick they seem to be
pretty healthy so what's so special
about this salt in relationship to
pathogens well salt is very
anti-microbial it has antiviral
properties antibacterial anti-fungal
anti yeast anti-mold so whatever's
growing in your sinuses or your lungs
you can take advantage of salt and it's
really good to break up thick mucus
there's many different ways you can
apply this depending on how much you
want to spend I mean the cheapest thing
is to go to the coastal region where
there's Sea Air and just you know be in
that environment just breathe that Salt
Air another thing you can do is just
take a teaspoon of sea salt dissolve it
in a glass of warm water and drink that
that actually helps as well you can go
to a salt house which is a little more
expensive you can get a Neti Pot which
they normally use saline solution you
can get a nebulizer and you can gargle
with salt water right very effective for
mucus in your throat now something a
little more expensive is using this
halotherapy or a Halo generator now the
term Halo comes from the Greek word
which means salt okay so what's
interesting about this Halo generator
and I've done a video just introducing
people about it it uses a dry salt okay
it crushes just basically sodium
chloride it's not even sea salt because
apparently when when you use sea salt
with this machine it can give impurities
and kind of get stuck in your lungs so
you just want to use
pure like 99.99 pure sodium chloride it
crushes it up into very small particles
and then it has a way of shooting it
through the air through your room so as
you're sleeping at night you're
breathing in these very tiny salt
particles which have super absorbing
properties it can actually go right into
your skin it's very anti-inflammatory
anti-microbial and you will wake up
feeling like you can breathe a lot
better because it's going to thin the
mucus and help reduce
all that mucus that actually irritates
the Pathways in your respiratory system
now realize that most of these
respiratory infections are viral related
so you cannot
um use an antibiotic it's not going to
work so anything viral you definitely
just want to give it a course of time
three to seven days or even up to 10
days and nurture your immune system use
things without side effects I know a lot
of people with small children at the
first sign of a fever they're concerned
you know they want to get rid of that
fever but getting rid of the fever
increases the duration of the infection
so you want to let the immune system
take over and just nurture it help it
that fever is good it's actually cooking
these viruses so they can't survive and
you know the three common things I
always recommend is vitamin D vitamin C
and Zinc but it is normal for a child to
get sick it's part of the immune
training process it's not a bad thing
you don't want to keep your kids in a
sterile environment you want to let them
be exposed exposed to the environment so
their immune system can become very very
strong I know growing up I had a sore
throat several times a year pretty much
every year of my life growing up now I
rarely get sick because my immune system
is strong but anyway if you wanted a
simple solution to mucus in your sinuses
or your lungs salt is the best thing to
do for that and if you haven't seen my
video on the immune system in
relationship to what else to take I put
that video up right here check it out